morning today is national donut day a
lot of local shops are gearing up for a
very busy day right now and who better
to take a donut challenge than ron
futrell he can talk sports he can talk
donuts he's a homer right a homer in
disguise joining us at glaze in the
southwest valley ron this is serious
business
homer simpson does love his donuts as do
i here we're back in the mix right we're
in the bowels of glazed donuts here
we're mixing them up right now
yes we are does that look good that's
fresh as could be this is fort apache
and southwest part of the valley fort
apache and uh
sunset sunset d husband is joining us
here you're single though you're called
the husband but here i'm okay just
checking on that okay
i'm not single man no you're not okay
you are the husband okay yeah here we go
what's your favorite donuts here what
are we gonna do so these are actually um
some of our most popular ones right here
um this is going to be our horchata
donut right here with the churro on top
it's going to be a horchata icing not
enough sugar on that one with a churro
hey listen we got to put a lot of sugar
on there for you they got cinnamon uh
sprinkles on top as well man okay now
you got green donuts come on now green
donuts hey listen this right here this
is a a really really popular one as well
this is our green tea pistachio donut
actually um
it's a unique flavor man so yeah yeah
okay uno mas we got one more here this
one this one really looks good this one
this is actually my favorite one right
here this is a too faced donut there's
salted caramels and pecans i love this
right here man these little pearls right
there is the salted caramel parts should
i try this one yeah i think you should
try this one right here right here boss
so you got caramel and nuts on what size
of caramel the brown side is going to be
the salted caramel and then the pecans
the other side
there you go
oh no that's good stuff and the salt
salt on there is good yeah okay you got
some donuts yeah man i got some donuts
you got to take back to the guys down at
the uh office man these are for joe
right should we take this
take him to joe man and let him chime so
he can give us some feedback on them
keep your hands away man
[Laughter]
it's national donut day glazed donuts
this is we're doing all the all the
one-off doughnut places not the chain
places but the one that just has one
place place has one place to cook them
back here fresh
ford apache and sunset
no this i got d husband i got to tell
you this caramel with the nuts is is the
is the bomb is the choice is it what's
the cool thing to say it's it's highly
addictive that's what i say
very highly addictive but that's that's
dee's favorite right there man okay
you've got a busy day for you national
donut day
it out a lot happened we are cooking
we're in the mix we're trying some
donuts we're getting fat with a pee
right all right so there we go we'll be
i got another place i got to get to i'm
hoping to obey most traffic laws on my
way to the next stop we'll let you know
when we get there but it's the oldest
donut shop
in las vegas we're on our way
i like this pecans are one of my
favorite things so it works out well
that sounded like sweet and savory going
on there
that was good right i have a quick
request can we make d husband a regular
fixture of this morning so he's awesome
yes dee husband they want you okay
they're telling me back in the station
they want you to be a regular fixture
like
a donut specialist
what do you think
i don't
i don't know man i know
when you taste these
when you taste these you'll really want
that all right fair enough i can't see
the bomb though come on ron can you save
this donut slap
can you say that sure
yes we can yes can you say that
they're looking at your life no you
can't say that either ron thank you very
much
you gotta
don't give me something to report on um
the pecan and salted caramel there's a
two good combo right there i mean
no you're saying no to that no i'm all
about it yeah heather was drooling at
the green tea
the pistachio one too but the churro as
well
well you've got one with a churro on top
coming your way
against donuts
i'll try them all